all right kitty yeah
kitty uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
burbank california burbank yeah and tell
me about your family growing up you had
mom and dad um
i had my mom and my dad at first in the
beginning and um
two months into me being born my dad got
taken away for selling dope
so um i didn't have him growing up until
i was like 17 basically he was in prison
and um he got out like five years ago
and
him and my mom got back together so
so you were raised by your mom yeah i
was raised by my mom how would you
describe your childhood with mom
um i guess like um i get i got the good
end of the stick because um i was she
was kind of older when she had me and i
was i she put me in like catholic school
and trying to do her best with me so
yeah
a fairly good childhood nothing
yeah fairly good she kept me sheltered
kind of
yeah there's no abuse or anything like
that no i was just really sheltered what
kind of kid were you in high school
um well i was i was like studious in the
beginning towards the beginning of it
and then towards the end i started kind
of slacking and i just was like
didn't want to graduate it was getting
too hard like i got kicked out of my
catholic school
and um
yeah like i i was in
i finally
made it to like a
a regular school
and i just um i didn't want to be at
that school i wanted to be at the
continuation school next door like
because that my boyfriend was there or
whatever
so um i kind of just like i switched
over and i went over there
and um
i just started like smoking weed and
with him a little bit and just kind of
like um being more like
free because i had never had freedom
before like
like that because i was always in
private school so i kind of enjoyed it
the catholic school upbringing kind of
made me feel trapped yeah yeah
do you see your adult life kind of as a
reaction to that childhood
yeah
and you became a sex worker at what
at some point right like um
i think i was 18 when i you know first
sold my body
you did that on the street yeah
like somebody just pulled over and feel
like this guy you know
and um
he was like married or whatever and he
was just in my hometown like close by
where i go to high school or whatever so
i was just like um i knew the hotel
right there
and then um yeah
i got like 300 and then ever since then
like my parents they wouldn't like my
mom she would take care of me but like
she wouldn't give me like money you know
so i would just be in the stream like um
without any money
so
what what part of town were you working
in
tahunga up in the valley yeah
you were just doing this on your own or
did you have a pimp or something
no like um at first i was just doing it
my own
and um
and then like um
i guess just a little bit after that i
started kind of working with other
people you know um
like collaborating with other people
and um but these people happen to be on
drugs you know and so i started like
getting addicted to drugs
and to like the
people around the drugs
and so um
yeah i was like doing fine i just didn't
have any money or income and i was just
like
with my boyfriend or whatever
at the time
and supposedly he's like the love of my
life right now but like we never made it
to be together like made it to work out
like as an adult couple
he was like my childhood sweetheart or
whatever
so
so
is that at some point you transitioned
from there to being a sugar baby yeah at
some point um how did that happen
well i started like um
just being more adventurous like leaving
the house more and because i met this
guy this other guy fell in love like
again or something because i fell in
love pretty easy
so i just like i met this other guy and
like um
i wanted to go hang out with him you
know and he was like on on meth
and um
i was like okay like um i don't know how
easily i was just
to do it you know like i guess i met him
through other people that were doing it
too and so i was just like um i didn't
feel any like scared to do it or
anything i just was like all right
like and just so easily to get like
so vulnerable
on the street you know
meeting people and stuff like that like
hanging out in hotels and like just
meeting like people that are into that
stuff and it was like a completely
different world like i didn't know any
drug addicts like i didn't never seen
them in up close and personal
did drugs become an issue for you a
problem in your life yeah they did um
i actually
went like i got in trouble with the law
like the first time i ever did math i
caught a case i was like
with these other people that gave it to
me this other young girl she was like
younger than me
and um
that same day like um i wanted coke i
was looking for a coke because i used to
do like here and there like in high
school
but um
i was looking for coke and he gave me
like meth
and so ever since that day i got busted
like at cvs like stealing
and um
because the girl you know i thought she
she needed like i don't know what like
that drug really messes you up in your
in your brain to make you think like all
kinds of things you know like
like you know like it really messes up
with you know everything especially i
had not done it before
and i didn't know how bad it was like
and then um
later on i got in trouble again with the
law and because of it
so i kind of like that's what made me
like really stop and
um i got kicked out of my parents house
so um i was just like i had to stop this
drug and like the people i started i was
doing drugs with started like kind of
treating me bad like my ex-boyfriend he
started like getting
abusive with me physically abusive and
so i had to leave you know and my
parents didn't want to they didn't want
anything to do with me anymore
like i had to beg my sugar daddy to come
pick me up and
he um he picked me up that same day like
the first time i ever tried like
fentanyl
and um
they picked me up and i didn't even know
what that was
and i had just smoked it and i didn't
think they were coming because i was
begging them to come get me and they
didn't
um they didn't want to come
and so i was pretty like sat down and
depressed and in the house like there
was like a lot of people a bunch of
people doing different drugs and stuff
in different rooms
and so i was just like um i got invited
like to go hang out with this guy or
whatever he invited me and so i was just
like okay i was so down and just like
lonely like because i was texting and i
was trying to get my way out of there it
was so far away like in ago dulce
and so i didn't have a car at that time
and
yeah i was stuck out there and i was
like
too high on different drugs and didn't
know what i was even high on
and then they came and picked me up
finally and
yeah like i could just tell like that
they were just like so scared my mom and
dad were like so scared to have me
around or something
and i was just like um
they let me stay there for a little
while and then like they kind of like
did an intervention on me and kind of
made me like go and live with my sugar
daddy over here in downtown lane
so i did that instead of going to rehab
so i just thought that would help me get
clean and
for a while i didn't get clean like i
was like smoking meth over here and all
day
in the sugar daddy's house like um
but
i was you know
but i couldn't shake it because i still
had like the jugs on me like i don't
even know how i would end up with like
some jugs and i would get high so easily
like and i had it on my possession like
i had pookies and and i just like
i don't even know like how why i was
just like i thought i could finish it
all and then like once i finished it all
i would stop you know and it kind of
worked like it after that i just didn't
want to go back to that life anymore
like with my with my ex i didn't want to
like go back to being abused to go back
to like um back getting treated bad like
i get treated so much better now that
i'm like off of it so you're off yeah
the heart of drugs
yeah i've been off for like about a
a year or two i probably i slipped dogs
like last year
last summer
and i just did like a little bit right
here like inhaled smoke or something
like that and you know
so tell me about the sugar daddies that
you have had
okay the sugar daddies yeah um i usually
without naming names yeah i usually meet
them like online or whatever
and um
it's usually like really nice like
especially when when i get like what i
asked for because um you know a lot of
people like they always want to like
lower it completely down
do you want the price
yeah they always want to negotiate you
know is that before you guys even meet
yeah it's usually before meeting
and so you know because um i just don't
want to be in a sticky situation where i
get there and they don't want to pay me
or something you know so i'm kind of
like i don't even do it that much you
know because it's kind of it's hard to
find like a really good but sometimes
it's really good and they'll like even
uber me out there pay me what i ask for
and send me off my way happy with my
money is like
so
but you're currently with
you you have more than one sugar daddy
or just right now um
i have like um
i have my sugar daddy and then i have
like other ones that like you know they
try to
you know be regular with me
but they kind of you know start trying
to like make me their girlfriend
and then um
and then they try to tell me like they
don't have the monies right now it's
[ __ ] out but i kind of like i kind of
stopped like hanging out and like
doing stuff for free you know a while
ago so
do you where do you do you live with
your
daddy yeah i do so
i have to kind of work around that
schedule
so does he know that you're seeing other
guys
i think he does you know
i don't tell him because like you know i
don't openly talk about it because i
feel like that would make him upset but
um
i just kind of like have to slip away
and do my own thing sometimes like
we're not married so
have you been in love before
yeah
like um probably three times four times
and do you prefer this kind of
arrangement or it's money
is it money for companionship or is it
money for sex or a little bit of both it
depends like on the person because
sometimes like um
sometimes they you know they don't have
a lot of money but maybe they have
something like to offer and then you can
do like a trade or something you know
like um but do you prefer this lifestyle
where it's
you're being paid for your
yeah i do because um
i just like you know i've been in love
before and i just felt like i didn't
like
like no like i just
you know
it just took a lot of time out of my
life like where i could have been making
monies you know but i don't regret like
i don't of course i don't regret it you
know i just
i just hope if it's meant to be in the
future like it's meant to be in like in
the future
how old are you 25 you're 25 yeah
how many sugar daddies have you had um
roughly
maybe like
like 10 and they last for
different amounts different amounts of
times yeah
what's the longest you've had a
relationship going with one the one i'm
in right now you know he's been really
like um good to me and
stuff so i just stick with him you know
he lets me stay there and he kind of
saved me from like a bad situation where
i was at my parents didn't want to
support me anymore and they couldn't
handle me so
yeah he's like been my angel and stuff
what's more important do you love or
money
money's right now
i need to get like my stuff together and
my life together first before i feel
like i can like focus on to love at all
because i've been there like done that
trying to be
trying to be like with somebody and
think about love and i ended up being
like homeless in this guy's car
like because he lost his job and he had
a job when we met and everything was
normal and then like he just started
losing stuff like losing his job
losing his house like
and then i just ended up like living
with him in his car for a while and then
i just i just thought like no way this
is not love like this cannot be love
like i mean if this is love i'd i care
more about money you know
i'm sure the attention of men or and or
love
comes easily to you right yeah exactly
so it's like pick or choose like pick
pick and choose what exactly what do i
want you know to get that without the
money yeah it seems like a waste of time
right yeah it's pretty sad it's pretty
sound life without money you know
you don't have kids
no no
no i have a little dog and she's like my
emotional support dog i almost wanted to
bring her but she's not trained she
won't shut up half the time so
what is your dream
situation like what would you like to
see happen in kitty's life um i would
like to be a psychologist one day or a
sex therapist
yeah
what do you think most women don't know
don't understand about men
that um
like they're pretty much just gonna do
what they want to do
do you feel like just a sex object
sometimes
yeah but you know i i don't like try to
try to victimize myself that way you
know
you you probably enjoy the attention of
men yeah i do
the cert you've had surgeries i take it
yeah i've had two surgeries so far um
gonna get another one soon and next
month what are you getting next another
moved on so even larger yeah even larger
and i want to get more later too but i
need more monies for that
what emotions do you go through do you
get depressed or angry or anxious or
anything like that
um i guess i can get like
um
like fear missing out
and like a little bit isolation and
stuff like that like um
i feel like i don't fit in anywhere like
i you know i tried so many times to like
get a job like around town and stuff
like that and i just feel like i just
don't fit in like
but um i'm happy i found like a little
doll right there that kind of keeps my
mind off things and it's kind of like
i really am passionate about like
cannabis so i
i like my job
what was the best time of your life
what's your favorite
um memory best time of my life was
my favorite memories were um
i mean i have really good um like
memories like
you know last night i just made some
good memories like kind of
i i've been getting closer to my parents
like after everything
that was a really good moment for me
last night we just had dinner and i was
just like so happy like just to so
you're rebuilding that relationship yeah
just to rebuild with them
what's what was the worst the hardest
time for you
the hardest time was probably like um
when my mom like called the cops on to
me
and she didn't want to let me in the
house because like i was um because i
was object or whatever
and i was like sleeping outside and i
was just like so high i couldn't even
like
i couldn't even like figure out what to
do or like where my stuff was
and they had to actually escort me out
like that was probably one of the worst
moments in my whole life but
do you have friends do i have friends
not girlfriends
like no
i don't and like i have just like family
my sisters which i
i'm not really very close to right now
sometimes i am sometimes not
it goes really up and down with them
do you feel like you're misunderstood by
most people
yeah
definitely
what do you think people don't
understand about kitty when they meet
you
i don't think they understand that i'm
like a really nice person
you know
i think they just probably like see how
i dress or see like um
or just think that i'm stuck up or
something
but um
i'm really just like nice and i'm pretty
shy but
i'm really just like a nice girl
like underneath it all
you have any regrets in your life
um
yeah i mean
i regret stealing from the law and
that's what got me into you know
troubles with the law
and i had like money in my pocket i
think so
it's just kind of like
i regret that you know
kitty what you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um the most important lesson i've
learned is to just be good to the people
like that love you and are around you
and don't hurt them
all right kitty thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you and i wish
you lots of luck thank you thank you
very much
you